جدل واسع اثارته دعوه جديده اطلقتها اليسا
الى اللاجئين في لبنان مطالبه اياهم
بالعوده الى بلدانهم الجدل بدا عندما
شاركت الفنانه تغريدات تنتقد وجود
اللاجئين وتعتبرهم عبئا يرهقك الى الدوله
اقتصاديا وسياسيا ما اثار ضدها انتقادات
لاذعه تضمنت اتهامات بالعنصريه وبعد
الهجوم ضدها غردت اليسا مستغربه من
الاتهامات بقولها لا اعتقد انني اهين احدا
عندما اطالب بعودته لوطنه لاني احبكم
بتمنى ترجعوا لاوطانكم وبتزامني مع
استمرار الجدل على تويتر ردت الفنانه
السوريه اصاله على اليسا داعيه الى مراعاه
ظروف اللاجئين الصعبه وكتبت قائله كلنا
بالارض لاجئين ولا احد يملك اي مكان باي
ارض وانتم شاركونا ما رايكم بموقفي اليسا
[موسيقى]